[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today let's go
to Brian in Philadelphia what's up
Brian hey how are you good what's
up um so I just had a quick question I
don't really have any sort of um issue
with saving money but my question is
about uh student loan debt uhuh um I got
lucky with it and I got half of my
college paid for and I went to a cheap
School sweet um so I only have about
12,500 um I have more than enough saved
up where I could just pay that off and
not have you know not have that debt
right but um I have not been making
payments on it due to the pause and
thinking that maybe um it'll be it'll be
canceled or at least $10,000 so my
question is is it worth just tackling
and knocking out or is it a better idea
to just continue making payments and
Brian love it does it make you feel warm
do you love
it do I love what the
loan I do not love the loan no like when
nobody's around you go in like your room
and shut the door just hug it do you
love it Brian the dream of the dream of
forgiveness died several months back pay
it off right now what are you doing pay
it off and
and um I'm GNA say something It Might
Sting M okay um pay off your student
loan and and do it with knowing inside
your heart man this is awesome that I
have the money to pay this
off because so many folks call our show
and they don't have the money to pay it
off not today and not for a couple for
several years on down the line and when
you wait out for forgiveness people who
didn't even take out student loans or
have their own they're fitting the bill
and so when you have the money to pay
pay so that other people who didn't even
have student loans aren't going to have
to pay through any type of who knows
what'll come down the pipe you know next
election year or whatever maybe
somebody's going to talk about
forgiveness again but always remember
nothing's free like first rule economics
there's no such thing as a free lunch
right everything costs and it costs the
taxpayer and if you're a person in this
country that can pay the bills that they
signed up to pay pay it you called the
wrong two people because both Jade and I
paid off hundreds of thousands of
dollars and I'll tell you right now
Brian if if those if those forgivenesses
went through and Miss Jade had to add
that to her taxes I'd be fired up cuz I
already paid
280,000 you know what I'm saying Brian
yeah the part about the timeline and and
I definitely got your answer uh on that
and I kind of had a suspicion that you
might say that yeah um but I was
actually to pay it off and then right
when I was about to pay it off the whole
thing came up that it might just be
forgiven so I figured if I paid it and
then it immediately would have been
forgiven I would have thought to myself
I should have invested that money
elsewhere but you know I totally get
your point though I think there's a
bigger thing there's and I think we lose
this this I think we lose this um
globally there is a a psychological and
in turn a physiological response to
Integrity to standing up and and keeping
your word telling the truth there's a
reason why truth telling is woven into
the fabric of every Faith tradition in
human history there you you walk
differently and when I was 18 and I
signed up for all the stupid loans I
signed up for I had no idea what I was
signing out for Jade need I mean none of
us did we were just doing the next thing
that everybody told us but we both put
our names on a piece of paper and said
if you help me get through school I'll
pay you back you did too and so I can
see that you would have been like dude I
got $10,000 more in my pocket you know
we got bailed out by the government
Jade's right number one anytime any time
a government agency bails you out they
will come knocking for a piece of Flesh
at some point if you've ever sat in a
history class they will come back to
your door and say where's mine so always
kind on that but the big thing is is you
would you would be like oh man I should
have invested it but I did what was
right because I put my name on a piece
of paper and I said I'd pay you back and
there you go here's my money and I'm I'm
moving on to the next and you know what
thanks for that call Brian because we
needed to talk about this with with the
people don't you think that everyone
would like to open up their bills and go
ah I'm not going to pay
that I mean no one wants to pay their
bills no one wants to give away money
like it doesn't feel good and it doesn't
it's not fun especially when you didn't
realize what you're doing yeah
absolutely but I'm saying it's it's not
fun to write your check for your car pay
or you know pay online I'm sorry I just
aged myself no one wants to send that
online pay payment for their car but
they signed up to have a car payment no
one wants to send you know even though
this is a little bit better you know
your insurance payment you know and
you're like gosh I never even use this
thing and it's not fun to give away your
money but when you sign up for something
you say that you're going to pay for it
and there is that piece of it that's
there and when it comes to these student
loans yeah I I can really get into this
here's the thing and I want to validate
this because I felt that John I'm sure
you have too with student loans is very
different because you're looking around
you're going yeah I was 18 somebody
should have stepped in like it would
have been nice if some adult had gone
hey Jade you don't need to take out that
much student loans because you know
you've got a full R scholarship you
don't need to take out student loans to
get your hair done and go to parties and
buy groceries like that's dumb Jay don't
do that I would have loved if an adult
did that I would have loved if an adult
stood and really explained compound
interest to me when it's working against
you I would have loved that but nobody
did I would have loved so many things to
be different about that situation for
the people to say hey don't put your
loan on forbearance CU When you do that
it's going to accumulate interest in you
faster than you've ever could imagine no
one did that and I can spend my whole
life blaming them or I can go oh let me
change my whole life I can't blame my
way to a better life I've got to change
the situation pay off your debt that's
all it is man